تتسع دائره التممل في صفوف الجيش
الاسرائيلي احتجاجا على ما يصفونه بتحول
النظام في اسرائيل نحو الديكتاتوريه من
خلال تعديلات سيؤدي اقرارها الى تحول نظام
العداله في اسرائيل الى ذراع سياسيه في يد
التحالف الحكومي الذي يهيمن عليه
اليمينيون المتطرفون مخرج الى العلم في
الايام القليله الماضيه من صفوف العسكر
وصف بغير المصبوق جنود وضباط من وحدات
قتاليه نخبوبيه قرروا استبدال مهامهم
العسكريه بخطوات احتجاجيه كل حسب اختصاصه
جنود الاحتياط الذين يعتبرون جزءا مهما من
الجيش ويتم استدعائهم عاده لما يصل الى
شهرين في السنه حتى في اوقات السلم انضم
اليهم ايضا رفاقهم في سريه لواء جولاني
ووحده ايكوز طيرون من الاحتياط في سرب
النخبه الذي يعتبر الاكثر اهميه في سلاح
الجو به مهام بعيده المدى وحده جبال الالب
التي تنشط في جبل الشيخ بالجولان المحتل
وحده تسمى راكب السماء التابعه لسلاح
المدفعيه التي تسير طائرات هجوميه من دون
طيار اعضاء في هذه الوحدات وقعوا على
عرائد رفعت الى قادتهم وتضمنت عبارات وصفت
بالقاسيه اقلها الامتناع عن التطوع في حال
استمرت دفع بخطه اضعاف جهاز القضاء خطوات
رفعت من مستوى القلق لدى قناه الجيش
الكبار واعضاء في التحالف الحكومي بزعامه
نتنياهو الذي وصف موقف الطيارين بانه
تهديد وجودي لاسرائيل بدورهم تشبث وزراء
في التحالف الحكومي بمواصله السير في
التعديلات التشريعيه حتى ان وزير
الاتصالات في حزب الليكود شلون مكرحي قال
للجنود المعترضين ان يذهبوا الى الجحيم
وفقا لوسائل اعلام اسرائيليه فان جنود
الاحتياط الذين التقوا بوزير الدفاع لبحث
القضيه خرجوا من الاجتماع محبطين وتعتريهم
مشاعر الصدمه